today on the Matt Walsh show I'm going
to share a few thoughts about my
experiences at University of Maryland
lesson I was giving a talk there on the
lefts war on reality and leftists on
campus where we're not terribly thrilled
to have me there it turns out which
course is to be expected but there were
there's a few points I want to make
about about what happened last night I
want to talk about the incredible
intellectual cowardice of left-wing
campus protesters and how that cowardice
is instilled by and encouraged by the
universities in so many cases and also I
want to talk about why labels like
bigoted and fascist don't mean anything
anymore and have no effect and so if
you're someone who relies on using those
labels to shut down debate or to try to
win an argument maybe you've noticed
that it doesn't seem to be working that
well well I want to explain why so we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including the effort by thousands of
people to try to shut down
pornhub now even if you're not on board
with the banning porn bandwagon can we
at least agree that a website like
pornhub should be if not shut down at
least heavily regulated we'll talk about
that and today in our daily cancellation
I have to unfortunately cancel some
people who are very close to me
personally I don't want to do it but I
have to and I'll explain why I think
after I explain you'll you'll understand
my decision and in our email section
today we will only answer a couple
emails including one from Andrew who
wants to tell me why I'm wrong about my
stance on gay marriage he apparently
attended my talk last night and had
issued took issue with one of the things
I said on gay marriage thinks I'm wrong
and he'll try to make his case so we'll
get into all of that coming up but first
yeah so I wanna I went to Cal College
Park last night University of Maryland
to give my war on reality speech and
there were Flyers and leaflets that went
up around campus before I showed up
there warning people about me saying be
very careful encouraging everyone to
stay away because I am hazardous to your
health it turns out now I showed you one
of the Flyers yesterday and here's
another one I'll put it up on the screen
for you this one
caution this event is a threat to all
LGBT plus people Matt Walsh is a raging
trans Fobo a faux racist and fascist he
is not arguing in good faith and
advocates for the criminal
well actually it says the
criminalization the criminalization and
institutionalization of all LGBT plus
people this is the kind of rhetoric that
gets us killed
we will not entertain debate about
whether everyone deserves rights and
basic human dignity on behalf of the
LGBT student population of UMD do not
engage with this speaker or attend his
event leave now by participating in this
event you are endangering all LGBT
people and cannot claim goodwill toward
any of us now for the people who did
show up you were endangering LGBT people
just simply by being there I don't know
if you knew that leave now
get out get out while you still can and
they they took this advice at least the
leftist people who disagreed with me
they did not show up they did show up
why I should say they showed up outside
of the room where they were handling
handing out brochures and telling people
not to come but they didn't actually
come in as far as I could tell not one
of them came in to the talk itself and I
assume that because during the Q&A
portion many people went up to say
something there wasn't I received no
challenge at all no pushback from the
left during the Q&A and I I guess
because they didn't come in they were
afraid I was gonna kill them I'm a
threat to the lives of LGBT people which
is really unreasonable I mean look at
most okay
I will kill one person at my talks
once I killed two people but generally
just one person so caught it's just one
look at you kill one person at each talk
and suddenly it's a big deal and it's
not a bigoted thing it's more of a
ritualistic thing to appease the gods so
we do a you know it's it's sort of a fun
things audience participation they all
select one person you know we'll do
different ways I'll take a volunteer
most of the time there is no volunteer
surprisingly but so then we'll we'll
talk about it as an audience a lot of
fun and we select one person we kill
them you know just as a ritualistic
thing then I get going with it because
here's I took public speaking classes
and I learned that you always want to
get the audience's attention first
before you start talking and what better
way to get their attention then by
ritualistically sacrificing someone to
the gods so that's it other than that
there's really no need for concern I
think but I think you know actually
anyway they weren't really worried that
I physically kill anyone they were
worried that my words would kill people
or get people killed how is that why and
what way would my words get anybody
killed nobody could explain nobody
bother explaining they didn't come in to
tell me now also as I said they were
handing out pamphlets outside the event
I managed to get my hands on one of
these pamphlets I want to show to you in
just a second because you have to see
this thing it's pretty it's pretty great
but before I do I want to take a pause
here to talk about our friends over at
Ashford University we all have an idea
of what our dream job would look like I
think we all we all know what that is my
dream job is is doing this which is not
a job so I don't really even have a job
which is really my dream as a lazy
person but a lot of people you want to
get a real job and some ones you know
you're not just gonna find someone's
gonna hand it to you odds are you'll
need at least a bachelor's degree to
make that dream of reality that's the
way that it goes in society today and I
know it's hard to go back to school
while you're still working so if you're
you know if you're especially you're an
adult you have kids your parent you want
to go back to school be very difficult
thing to do it's a very daunting thing
to think about but that's why you'll
love Ashford University Ashford
University's online bachelor's and
master's degree programs allow you to
learn at your own pace you can study
wherever you're the most comfortable
learning Ashford University's six-week
long courses allow you to take one
course at a time being enrolled in one
class at Ashford means you are
considered a full
I'm students who are taking on a on a
manageable workload which will also work
with everything else you got going on
your life and we all have busy lives and
that's what Ashford University
understands you know I I know a number
of people who as adults as parents are
saying I want to go back to school I
want to get the degree how am I going to
do that and that's why I tell them you
know Ashford University is is the way to
go because it'sit's gonna work with your
life there are no standardized tests
required either the SAT GRE G mats other
standardized test scores are not
required for rolling at Ashford
University so you can get on the road to
earning your degree and making your
dream job a reality enroll now by going
to Ashford dot edu slash wall studs
Ashford dot edu slash walls to start
your degree today Ashford dot edu slash
Walsh okay now they were handing okay so
they're handing out these brochures
brochures I know I pronounced it that
way these brochures they were handing
them out at to talk and here's here's
what this one looked like I don't if
you'd see that this is the bro the
brochure and it says the war on reality
well actually says the war on Realty I'm
not sure if that spelling mistake is on
purpose or not I don't know why it would
be on purpose the war on Realty
yeah real estate I guess I'm on waging a
war in real estate as someone who's sold
a house twice now in my life I I do kind
of want to wage a war a real estate and
then it says featuring Matt wasp Matt
loss of the dahle wire clever stuff
that's devastating remember I've said in
the past that it's very difficult for
people to think of ways to change my
last name in an insulting way go as a
kid many many bullies tried and failed
because Walsh is just there's not a lot
you could do with it here they try wasp
not even really correct because wasp is
white anglo-saxon Protestant I'm
Catholic so really I'm a wasp and and
then at this is young America's foul
nation rather than foundation and then
inside there's the same thing I showed
you the same
poster thing about how I'm a trans phobe
and then there's a hole in the brochure
it lists a number of my very disturbing
viewpoints so it gives a little bit of a
run down a resume of all of my bigoted
and horrific things that I believe and
I've said in my life and just for
example it says voting rights Matt Walsh
staunchly endorses stripping people of
the right to vote if he considers them
to be ignorant or non-contributing I do
I do support that actually and
specifically only wants people to vote
if they pay taxes and it passed in
eighth grade civics is in yes what's the
problem with that yes I am fully on
board with stripping lots of people of
their voting rights I've been very clear
about this I uh I ran a CLE believe that
millions of people should not have the
right to vote who currently do and I I
think we should take that right from
them I absolutely believe that if you
can't pass an eighth grade civics exam
you have no business voting I think you
should not have the right to vote this
system was never set up to give
literally every single person the right
to vote and it doesn't work that way
it doesn't work we don't need every
ignoramus every non-contributing [ __ ]
to vote that's not what the founding
fathers had in mind that's the system
just doesn't work anyway and then it
goes through and a bunch of all my other
things
Walsh spends much of his bandwidth
attacking a handful of progressive
figures such as Bernie Sanders and
Alexander Kaiser Cortes yeah yeah that's
true too
anyway it's very unfortunate that they
didn't actually come into the room to
the talk itself because I was really
hoping that last night would be the
night finally that after all of these
many months of asking that I could
finally get a leftist to define the word
woman for me you know it's been my goal
as you know to get someone on the left
to offer a definition I was really
hoping it would happen last night during
the QA finally but that hope and dream
was dashed now and so this is this is
the the really unfortunate thing it the
stifling suffocating intellectual cow
of these people it's it's fun to laugh
at and easy to laugh at but to view
opposing ideas as a tax as mortal
threats rather than opportunities
opportunities to sharper you sharpen
your own mental tools to test your ideas
in your perceptions to engage with
different viewpoints to grow as a person
rather than viewing it as that they view
it as a mortal threat to their very
lives and we've gotten so used to this
that we're numb to it and everybody says
yeah that's the way it goes on college
campuses but let's not lose sight it is
the way it goes but let's not lose sight
of how extraordinary it is that it's
become this it's not it shouldn't be
normal it might be normal but it
shouldn't be people not just any people
but young young people talking about
young people here who view opposing
ideas as physical threats to their
safety and these again are people in
college an institution of learning we're
thinking is supposed to be the whole
point of the exercise we're encountering
challenging ideas is supposed to be one
of the one of the great benefits of
going to a university
see it's supposed to be old people old
and world-weary people there's supposed
to be the ones who are set in their ways
set in their ideas set in their opinions
in movable I'm not saying I'm not saying
it's good even for older folks to be
that way I don't think anyone should be
that way but I mean at least it's
understandable if you're a 75 year old
guy and you're saying you know what this
is who I am this is what I believe this
is what my opinions are I'm too old now
I'm not changing this I'm gonna ride
this out even if I'm wrong I'm riding
this thing out to the end because it's I
got other things to worry about in fact
no I don't want to worry about anything
I'm just god I'm gonna kick back and
relax not worrying about about debating
you you little whippersnappers anymore
so I understand that mentality from an
older person if you're 75 but 19 20 and
you're gonna block out all other ideas
at that age you're supposed to be
experimenting with ideas fearlessly
at that age again I think you should be
doing that at any age and it's great too
because it's okay to be wrong especially
when you're young people expect you to
be wrong so you've got nothing to lose
you know you when you're when you're 19
you're in college you don't have any
family no dependents not you have no
real responsibilities you can be wrong
about anything there isn't really no
consequence to being wrong people expect
it no one's worried about it so be as
wrong as you want you know I think and
and there used to be this stereotyping
that you still find this sometimes among
college-age kids where they go they they
go wildly from one extreme to another
and one second you see them and they're
a radical communist the next thing you
know there are libertarian and they're
back and forth like a like a pinball
machine all these different views and
they get very invested in this view and
then they're over here and over there
but that actually is good I think that's
what that's sort of what youth should be
because you're experimenting with ideas
you've got that youthful enthusiasm so
when you stumble across an idea that you
think is interesting you get very
invested in it but then you know you're
still open to others your reading and
your thinking and so now next thing you
know you're over there and you're back
and forth that's fine I think that's
what being young should be all about but
now it's become not that at all now it's
this is my viewpoint as as as irrational
and deranged as it might be I'm not
changing this is what I believe and I
simply will not allow myself to even
come in contact with any other ideas
right this is these are my ideas and and
I'm quarantine like the coronavirus I'm
quarantined myself that's how they I did
think about that last night this is this
is how they treat opposing ideas they
treat it like a if you have an opposing
idea they treat you like you have the
chronic virus and they're gonna
quarantine you stay away they're just
one step away
from asking for from demanding that you
wear a surgical mask so that your
opposing ideas don't don't leak out you
know unintentionally and infect somebody
now so that that's one problem the
intellectual cowardice the other thing
is this calling everything bigoted and
this is part of course the way of trying
to shut down debate call everything
bigoted and fascist and you heard in the
brochure there I'm a bigot fascist
fascist racist all of those all those
various ist's and phobias that's the way
these things always go but it has no
effect anymore nobody cares about being
called these things I don't care at all
people ask me sometimes how do you deal
with the labels people call you bigoted
and how do I deal with it I do not care
at all it means nothing to me
that has no effect it should though it
should mean something to me it actually
should I should care about somebody
calling me a bigot because bigotry is
real it's a bad thing to be a bigot so I
think maybe there was a time when you
accused somebody of being a bigot that
was a serious charge but now it's it's
so common that I can't afford to care
and this is the analogy that I use
yesterday my talk to try to explain why
it works this way now let's say that you
bought a bottle of rat poison because
you have a rat problem in your house and
you got the rat poison would you then
with your rat poison go and label every
container in your home rat poison just
to be cautious just to be safe you're
gonna call everything rat poison what
you wouldn't do that because the other
people in your home you know your kids
your wife or if you your parents or your
siblings
now they're not gonna be really sure
what the real rat poison is because
you've called everything rat poisoning
and the result is after a while they're
going to ignore the labels because they
have no choice because it's the only way
to function now and they're gonna live
their life the problem is that there
actually is rat poison in one of those
containers and now you've just increased
the likelihood that someone is going to
come in contact with
ingest the rat poison because you've
negated the effectiveness and a meaning
of the label in a similar way when you
go around reflexively labeling every
opinion you don't like bigotry or
fascism you've made it so that those
labels mean nothing nobody can take them
seriously anymore and then what do you
do when there actually is bigotry or
fascism to fight do you say well you
can't you can't say hey look it's a
bigot it's a fascist you can't say that
well you can but no one's gonna listen
everyone's gonna yawn and say oh yeah
well that's what you said about the last
19,000 people you came in contact with
so and that's really a problem because
again there is actual bigotry is a real
thing fascism is a real thing there are
racists out there but you've called
everyone that and so not only have you
it's not just that you've made the label
meaningless but now you've you've really
caused more people to go you know and
end up becoming bigots because when you
try to warn someone away from that
bigoted worldview they're gonna say you
call everything bigoted so now you're
saying this is bigoted to maybe in this
case it actually is but you have no way
of telling them that you have no word
left to describe actual bigotry I guess
this is a just a way a way of retelling
the boy who cried wolf I suppose so I
could I could probably keep it at that
but and that's that's what it is so even
if I am a bigot or a fascist which I
don't think I am but even if I was you
calling me that has no effect that has
no meaning it has no substance because
that's what you say about everybody all
right we're gonna get two headlines in a
second but first time is running out to
get 25% off all daily wired membership
plans using coupon code never socialist
this is the last week we're giving you
this offer and you you just you don't
want to miss out on on the with
everything going wrong in the world
right now we're giving you this great
offer
you'll want to compound your problems by
missing out on this wonderful offer
daily wire members get an ad-free
experience show library including the
Matt wall show the full three hours of
the ben shapiro show access to the
mailbag and now the exclusive election
insight op-eds from ben shapiro daily
wire members also get to ask us
questions live like many of you saw that
super tuesday coverage a backstage along
with all this of course you get the
magnificent the irreplaceable the the
the singular the beautiful leftist
here's tumbler and if you haven't
already download the daily wire app so
you can get all of our great content on
the go with you wherever you go again
that's 25% off on delhi wire memberships
for all plans using coupon code never
socialist so head on over to delhi
wired.com slash subscribe the deal is
ending this week so join now that's
daily wire.com slash subscribe headlines
number one bernie sanders has officially
unveiled his extremist pro-abortion
agenda for if he becomes president he's
calling it the reproductive justice plan
reading let me read now from a report in
one of my favorite websites life site
news that says Democrat presidential
contender and avowed socialist senator
Bernie Sanders has formally unveiled the
abortion agenda he's running on in 2020
collecting in a single location the
various absolutist promises he has made
to the abortion Lobby the Vermont
senators so-called reproductive health
care and justice for all plan pledges to
repeal the Hyde Amendment thereby
allowing direct funding of elective
abortions with tax dollars make
contraception free and available
over-the-counter and significantly
expand funding for Planned Parenthood
title ten and other initiatives that
offer and promote abortions okay a lot
of problems here of course let's start
with funding Planned Parenthood he wants
to dramatically increase funding for
Planned Parenthood they already get half
a billion dollars a year this is a a
billion dollar corporation that gets
half a billion a year in tax funding
Sanders and Leggett wants to give them
more so Sanders the guy who hates
billionaires hates corporations is
actually okay with giving billions to a
corporation he's the corporate welfare
guy now
but only if they kill babies think about
that the only corporation that Bernie
Sanders likes and actually
like so much they wants to give more
money to more than half a billion is the
one that kills babies this man is a
demented freak is that harsh maybe a
little but deserved number two speaking
of Bernie Sanders he said on Fox
yesterday that it would be xenophobic to
shut down the border even in the case of
trying to contain a viral pandemic but
if you had to if you had to would you
close down the borders no I mean what
you don't want to do right now we have a
president who has a propagated
xenophobic anti-immigrant sentiment from
before he was elected what we need to do
is have the scientists take a hard look
at what we need to do there are
communities where the virus is spreading
what does that mean it may mean self
quarantine it may be not having public
assemblies but let's not go back to the
same old thing isn't it interesting that
a president who has been demagoguing and
demonizing immigrants the first thing
that he could think about is closing
down of the border so we need scientists
that tell us the appropriate approach
not a political okay
we see again here that leftist positions
are actually religious doctrines there
is no reason at all to oppose shutting
down the border in case in the case of a
pandemic unless it's just an obvious
thing that you would do unless you
believe in a doctrine that says shutting
down the border is intrinsically immoral
controlling the border is intrinsically
immoral which is nonsense obviously but
that's their religious conviction and
that's why they can never be talked out
of it
number three Representative Paul Gosar
is in self-quarantine he tweeted
something esterday that's went viral for
all the wrong reasons
here's the tweet he says been thinking
about life and mortality today I'd
rather die gloriously in battle than
from a virus in a way it doesn't matter
but it kind of does and there's a
picture there of guys and chain-link
armored sword fighting and so he's in
self quarantine worried about the virus
thinking I'd rather die that way
which people are making fun of them
don't we all feel that way I certainly
agree only personally I've always
imagined and hoped that my demise would
come when I trip when I trip running
away from some pursuing monster or enemy
of some kind and there's a whole group
of us and then and then I trip on a root
or something and and and I say to the
other people you go on without me and
they stop they say no no we're gonna
take it and I and I and I say I look at
them resolutely and I say no no go and
then as they're turning to leave I say
something inspiring like you know I'll
live on in your heart not that exactly
I'm workshopping it's still a little bit
but of course but but the main thing is
there is no reason for me to tell them
to go on without me because I could have
gotten up you know in all the movies the
person trips is there's going on without
me you could easily just get up and keep
running but you decided it's not worth
the effort so I'm just gonna die
so that's my plan anyway but we all have
our dreams number four on the subject of
the virus people in France are throwing
caution to the wind in spite of the
corona outbreak and they're doing
whatever in the hell this is
okay so that was 3,500 people dressed
like Smurfs gathering together to break
the world record I'm not sure what the
record is exactly presumably the world
record for the most embarrassing thing
that a group of people have ever done in
their ever in history or maybe it's the
world record for most people who've
gathered together as Smurfs which means
that there have been other groups and
other occasions like this of smaller
groups of people gathering as Smurfs in
fact this you know I mean this goes back
I believe this is how the Black Plague
started maybe the blue plague we should
call it all I could say is if France is
ultimately decimated by disease because
thousands of people passed it to each
other and a giant Smurf gathering well
there's just something about that that
seems appropriate
it's very on-brand for France it seems
to me number five from the Daily Caller
reading now the report it says pornhub
struck back Monday at a petition to shut
down the website demanding that the
pornography platform be held accountable
for the role it's accused of playing in
sex trafficking and allowing child rape
films director of abolition for Exodus
cry Lila Mikkel Waite told the Daily
wire news the Daily Caller news
foundation I should say that she has
focused her efforts for the past eight
years on the connection between
pornography sex trafficking and sexual
exploitation her change.org petition
calls for the government to shut down
pornhub and hold its executives
accountable for aiding trafficking and
it's garnered more than 400,000
signatures since it was created February
10th the petition criticizes pornhub for
allegedly failing to have a system to
reliably verify the age and consent of
those depicted in pornography and it
goes off there pornhub is responded
saying that this is wrong and this is a
radical right-wing attempt to shut us
down and and so on now I think we'll
talk more in detail about this later on
in the week because this is worth worth
focusing on more intently but we've
talked about the issue of trying to ban
porn and I realize that on that position
I am very much in a minority which I'm
in a minority in a lot of my positions
so I'm used to it but even if you no
matter how you feel about banning porn
let's let's put that conversation to the
side for a moment we should be able to
agree at a minimum as decent rational
people that a website like pornhub that
has billions of hours of pornography
it's the largest porn site in the world
by a mile in and and many of those
videos many many many thousands of hours
of that content consists of rape porn
and child porn I think we
be able to agree that a company like
that should face some regulations at
least some controls and it should be
required by law to put a to put
something in place to verify that the
content it's allowing on its platform is
not rape or child molestation we should
be able to agree on that they should be
for acquired by law to ensure that they
are not allowing child porn and rape
films on their platforms and they should
also be required by law to make sure
that the people viewing to put you there
should be some age restrictions on the
content and there should be subtly there
should have to put something in place to
ensure that the people viewing the
content are not kids because as it
stands right now you know just having to
click yes I'm 18 that's not going to cut
it there should be something more
something like you have to provide an ID
you know there are many ways you could
go about this and it's no matter what
you do ok it's it's not gonna be 100
percent but it'll be a lot better than
what it is now where there is
effectively no filter put in place
whatsoever to stop kids from getting on
the couch getting on the site and so
pornhub is making millions of dollars on
showing porn to kids and they know
that's what they're doing in fact they
even market to kids if you look at the
way that they market especially on
social media it is obviously tailored
oftentimes to kids so this again we
should be able to agree and the only I
guess the what you might say as well but
if pornhub is required to make sure
they're not showing rape films and child
porn that might be too onerous and it
shut down the company okay what is that
supposed to be some sort of dystopian
worst-case scenario you know if you
can't run your company without ensuring
that your business doesn't involve
showing child porn and rape films to
millions of people you know if that is
an integral part of your business and
there's no way for you to weed it out
without your your company itself
shutting down well to me that's a really
good indication that your company should
shut down all right let's go to your
daily cancelation before we have emails
here in a moment
today I have a rather somber
cancellation that I have to do I don't
want to have to do this it's not
something that a parent ever wants to do
but it is something I think many parents
find that they must do there there comes
a time and so I must cancel my kids
today at least the older ones the twins
six years old and I guess my younger son
three years old I'm gonna have to cancel
him as well they're all canceled I can't
afford them I for I informed them this
morning you're all canceled canceled
canceled canceled while they're eating
breakfast and let me explain why I think
you'll sympathize over the weekend
actually was on Saturday Saturday
morning I was excited to finally show to
my kids and this is something I've been
waiting to do this for six years and I I
felt like the time is now that they're
ready and so I decided that I was gonna
show the kids the movie Space Jam now as
a kid Space Jam was for me one of the
great cinematic classics how could you
not love it combining Michael Jordan and
Bugs Bunny is just it's two worlds
colliding it's a it's like a dream come
true I probably I was Space Jam came out
when I think I was like nine I probably
watched it 40 times the first year came
out it was funny it was dramatic it was
inspirational
it was suspenseful it was at times sad
but ultimately uplifting Jordan's acting
was superb he was able to portray two
entire emotions mildly amused and mildly
concerned and those that was his range
it
incredible acting range I think I'm
betting that Daniel day-lewis as he was
watching Space Jam which I'm sure he has
we for any first saw he fell into deep
despair knowing that he would never be
able to act as well as Michael Jordan so
the point is this was a hugely
influential movie to me in my life and
finally it was time on a Saturday
morning
harkening back to my days of watching
looney tunes on a saturday morning
that's why i chose a saturday morning
everything was right time to show the
kids the movie and they were not
impressed at all they hardly pay
attention through the whole thing didn't
take it seriously no respect for the
artistry on display no respect for my
childhood and my emotional attachment to
this movie and finally when it was over
and I asked them what they thought my
daughter said her exact words it was
kind of weird and boring daddy
sorry and then my son said that it
reminded him a little bit of Zootopia
because of the bunny except Zootopia is
good that was what he said and I'll tell
you why it hurt so much it was the
realization realization that my kids are
uncultured Philistines who wouldn't know
great art if it fell on their head like
a cartoon handful and and and and by the
way which which they also don't
understand is the height of comedy an
anvil falling on someone's head and
they're squished down like a pancake
nothing is funnier than that happens in
space Jim they don't even crack a smile
I'm telling you right now I this this
weekend I've decided I'm going to show
my kids the neverending story as we as
we do this tour of my childhood films
and if they don't like that one I'm
calling the adoption agency it's it's
done enough is enough you gotta put your
foot down all right now let's go to
emails and you can email the show if you
become a member the other wire you get
access to the to the to the mailbag and
we'll and so look it's a one email here
in
and and then we also have as I said
Andrew who's gonna tell me why I'm wrong
all right this is from Rachel says dear
galactic Lord dictator and culinary King
I'm hoping you can pass along your
culinary skills slash expertise I have
noticed that whenever I have a meal at a
restaurant and enjoy it and then try to
replicate it at home
there's always something missing I can
never get it to taste the same I'm not
sure I've ever made a quote
restaurant-quality meal in my life where
am I going wrong
well Rachel I would need to know don't
take this the wrong way but I would need
to know your race and your location to
answer this question without that
information there's not much I can tell
you because I haven't had your cooking
which sounds like thank God I haven't
but the reason I need to know your race
and location is that if you are white
and not from the south so if you're a
white Yankee then I could tell you
without having your cooking I could tell
you right now exactly what it is I can
tell you what the problem is with a
hundred percent certainty you're using
you're not using enough butter you're
not using enough seasoning white
northerners have had this problem for
centuries now this is you know I think
this is one of the things the Civil War
was over the food is bland butter 'less
see what you understand about
restaurants restaurants put butter on
everything if you're asking why our
wife's food so good at restaurants is
because they put globs of butter on
everything they put a if you're having
green beans at a restaurant they put it
they put a gallon of butter on it
doesn't matter vegetables meat
everything butter butter butter that's
why it tastes so good
and that's why food in the south tastes
are in the south they understand this
they are just taking dump trucks of
butter and putting it on everything they
make down there they even they even you
walk into a house in the South they they
cover the walls in the end and the floor
with butter to everything as butter and
the food is great of course that's why
so many southerners are obese I think
eight of the fattest ten states of in
the Union are in the south but it's it's
worth it for the great food and then
seasoning this again is a problem among
white nor
the nurse not nearly enough see the
seasoning so if you're in that category
you should be using and I say this by
the way as a white / as a white
northerner myself okay so I'm allowed to
say everything I'm saying right now
these are these are insulting
stereotypes they are absolutely true and
so the other thing is the seasoning
problem now you and I have to tell
myself this because my friend I've had
to overcome this my I realize that my
first inclination is to use about a
quarter of the seasoning that I should
be so I need to when it feels like I've
used enough seasoning but four times
that amount on that's the rule of thumb
now if you're making a steak or
something a really nice cut of meat it's
a little bit different in that case
you're putting salt you're using the
butter the butter rule still applies but
you want to let the flavors of the meat
come out the salts gonna help with that
you don't want to drown it in seasoning
in that case but if for any dish that is
not a very nice cut of meat you want the
seasoning I was at a someone's house the
other day and they were making tacos and
I watched them put one packet of the
store-bought taco seasoning on two
pounds of ground meat ground beef
horrifying now you shouldn't be using
the packets anyway you should make that
at home but because you should have a
spice cabinet that has everything that
the taco seasoning is it that's in the
taco seasoning but if you're using the
packets you want at least three of them
for that amount of meat if not four
all right let's go to why I'm wrong this
is from Andrew says hi Matt I attended
your talk at college part Lacs Park last
night the University of Maryland I
really enjoyed it and thought you gave
easily the best speech of any
conservative I seem I've seen on campus
but I did have a problem with one
argument you made okay that way you just
ruined it so you compliment me and then
you and then you tell me that I'm wrong
didn't get a chance to talk to you about
it in the Q&A you said that only
heterosexual people should be able to
get married because only that Union can
serve as the basis of the family because
only they can procreate but you didn't
adequately address the fact that some
heterosexual unions are not fertile and
same-sex unions can still adopt how does
this not destroy your argument well hi
Andrew I think I
in a dress that it's true of course that
some straight couples can't have kids in
fact every straight couple is in that
boat eventually if they stay together
and if if they live long enough also
it's true that same-sex couples can
adopt but none of this has any bearing
on my point my point is that hetero the
heterosexual Union in principle has the
capacity to create life and this
capacity sets it apart from any other
Union in a similar way you know I might
say that human beings in principle have
two arms and two legs meaning these are
fundamental features as a general rule
human beings have two arms and two legs
if somebody were to say to you describe
what a human being looks like you're
gonna say you're gonna give a
description and it's going to include
two arms and two legs just like if I ask
you what does an elephant look like in
your description you're gonna mention
that the the trunk right that's what in
principle is general rule now a person
can lose an arm a person can be born
with a deformity and not have any legs
does this make them not human well of
course not but the point is that they
would have arms and legs if not for the
mutation or disease or injury that
caused things to be different for them
so they are exceptions but they are
exceptions that prove the rule because
if someone has one arm or no legs you
automatically know that something went
wrong automatically you know that there
was an injury there was a there was a
mutation there was an illness you know
that for sure because they're not
supposed to be that way and we know
they're not supposed to be that way
because we know in principle what a
human being is supposed to look like
now what happens of a spaceship lands
and creatures come out of the spaceship
and all the creatures have eight arms
and four legs be a little top-heavy but
well in that case we wouldn't know that
these creatures whatever they are are
not human this is not a case of a
minority of people who happen to have
fewer limbs than they ought to have
because of
some misfortune that befell them no now
we have a whole race of creatures who it
would appear in principle have eight leg
or eight arms and four legs or whatever
it is so they aren't human
that doesn't mean they have less moral
value necessarily than human beings do
it just means that there's something
different
they are something other we would call
them something different we wouldn't
call them human
okay back to marriage we have two things
here to consider one thing is the
heterosexual Union which in principle
has or at one point had barring illness
or deformity the capacity to in itself
create new life the other thing the
homosexual Union in principle does not
have and has never had and can never
have and will never have the capacity to
in itself create new life so these are
two things that are in principle
different we don't even need to get into
the moral valuations right now they're
just different I'm trying to get you to
that point of acknowledging the
difference and they're different in an
in a powerful and important way one of
these things creates people the other
does not I mean imagine if the rather
than marital unions we were talking
about in machines and you had one
machine that created people and another
machine that didn't do that okay well
these are different machines right and
you probably you wouldn't give them the
same name and and you would probably
come to the conclusion that the people
making machine is probably a little bit
more important because of what it does
because of a function because of its
purpose so my argument is the thing that
creates people should have a different
name be called something different and
should be valued by and protected by
society more simply because of its
crucial importance to society everyone
says well maybe the answer is to get the
government out of marriage the reason
the government the state had a vested
interest in marriage
is because of its procreative potential
and so that that makes it a something
that everybody is concerned with it
doesn't mean the entire world can barge
into your marriage and dictate terms and
have a say and everything you do it's
just that there's a real interest in
protecting and and encouraging the that
marital Union because it it serves as
the basis for the formation of new life
and and the family and the family is the
foundation of human civilization and so
of course human civilization is
interested in now the same-sex Union
doesn't have that capacity so society
has no real interest in it the state has
no real interest in it and that again is
apart from any moral evaluation it's
just it's there's not any it's just why
does society need to protect the union
of two people who are you know living
together or what-have-you but there's no
procreative potential there and and so
that's the difference that's that's my
point just remember that phrase in
principle and so that that I think will
help navigate all these exceptions and
civility and infertility and all the
things that you're mentioning Andrew and
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
oh and remember buy my book Church of
cowards God's beat okay
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Kleber show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]